wanted to start with a big broad career
question what is one thing about your
film making process that has stayed the
same from following to Oppenheimer but
then also what's something about it that
has evolved with the evolving you know
industry the technology we have even
viewer habits gosh big questions to
begin with uh I mean look honestly my
film making process is very very similar
to what I started with um um it's change
only in incremental ways and uh you know
I think that's one of the things I I
talk to you know young filmmakers about
independent filmmakers you know when
you're when you're starting out you're
making a no budget film as I did to
start the thing you have to remember is
that creative process of you know what's
the shot how is that going to move the
story forward what's the next shot
that's never really going to change and
so every time you make a film you have
to just enjoy it for the experience that
it is because it really is similar I
mean yes there's a lot more trucks and
trailers and you know hundreds of crew
around and everything uh but you really
have to keep your eye on the prize of
that that essential narrative
progression visually and how you're
going to sort of move that forwards um
and so I my process uh it really tends
to not change so I don't have a big you
know video village with big monitors or
anything I'm really just there by the
camera uh watching the actors to I um
and then watching dailies every night so
still sending the film to the lab having
them print it on on Celluloid we put it
up on a projector we sit there and watch
it every evening um so yeah it's a
reassuringly familiar process never
change please I love talking about how a
film evolves at every stage of the
process whether it's writing filming
editing but then also how it kind of
takes on a new life when you release it
out into the world so is there any
particular part of Oppenheimer that
wound up becoming stronger for you than
you ever could have imagined based on
how people responded to it and maybe
even interpreted it gosh I mean
I I feel that the audience has
interpreted and taken the film very much
in the spirit that I intended which is
obviously a huge relief particularly
with as as tricky and potentially
controversial subject matter as this
it's very serious subject matter um but
the strength of the response has so far
exceeded you know our highest hopes for
the film uh I mean to have particularly
young people you know 15 16 year olds
going you know dressed as up inimer to
the the movie theater watch the movie uh
these were not things we anticipated um
but as far as the particular directions
I I would say people the film has an
ambiguous response at the end people
seem very affected by it and that
started to become apparent as soon as we
started screening the film for
individuals as we were working on the
film so every time I screen the film for
a small number of of people there'd be
very strong reactions to the end people
would feel sometimes very upset uh not
necessarily for specific reasons though
it's a more generalized sense of I
suppose Despair and nihilism that that
you know is just inherent to the the
subject matter so uh really the strength
of the response the the breadth of the
response has been the big shock for us
it's such a special thing I can't even
begin to tell you how excited I was to
see something that is so specific to
your voice and not part of a franchise
just excelling and really like having
everybody out there appreciate it no
matter your age and also appreciating
the film making behind it too I feel
like a lot of people are being taken by
this story but they're also recognizing
certain elements that we don't usually
get to see and they're appreciating it
and that's important for continuing to
make movies like this basically I mean
definitely one of the I mean one of the
things that that we we got a very
visible response to was the uh
theatrical presentation the IMAX
presentation in particular using film
and using film prints that went out
there into the world those screens in
particular I mean we you know we broke
the alltime record man's Chinese with uh
the print we had there we I think as of
last weekend we became the third highest
grossing IMAX film In America which you
know after Star Wars and Avatar I mean
for a film about J Robert opheim was
extraordinary but that to me was a
response to um the care and attention we
were putting into the presentation of
the film as well as the film and it's
just thrilling to watch young people
owning movies in their own way and
saying what's important to them about
getting out of the house getting to a
theater and enjoying the film in a way
and it's really wonderful to see a new
generation doing that goes along long
way I'll preface this next question by
saying it's a little unfair because I'm
kind of asking you to pick a favorite
but you have an you have an especially
uh exceptional Ensemble here but in
particular there are so many wonderful
actors who have like mere moments of
screen time yet they still manag to make
their character feel like a fully
fleshed out living breathing person of
all of those lesser known actors in
those roles with less screen time is
there anyone who just really exceeded
your expectations where maybe you would
want to work with them on a lead role on
a future film I there's no diplomatic
way to answer that question but I the
the The Ensemble is terrific and the
headline stars have rightfully had an
incredible amount of attention but there
are people in the film like David crom
Hal's playing is itel Robie or Jack
quaade you know playing Richard fireman
who they have their moments and and they
move you and you know it's there are so
many more there are too many to name
honestly I'd be disappointing people by
leaving them out I already am uh there
everybody Dylan Arnold Dylan Arnold very
happy for him yes I mean there were so
many just they were able to come to set
knowing the characters they were playing
from history so they would come knowing
more than I did about them uh you know
Josh peek people like that you know
coming in and they they were able to
improvise
scenes uh you know and improvise some of
the discussion some of the arguments
around the bomb um you know so you have
not just Robert Downey Jr and Gillian
Murphy but you got Matthew Modine and
Josh hardnet these guys throwing ideas
around and and and everything and so as
a director that's just just the greatest
privilege I mean the the breadth of cast
I really should mention my casting
director John papsidera did a phenomenal
job it's I think it's one of the great
casts that's ever been a and I'm so glad
that you're you know pointing out some
of the smaller players behind thaton
Reich I'm desperately trying to come up
with they're all incredible though I I
mean uh we didn't even mention you know
Gary Oldman turning up playing President
Truman but uh I mean they're just just
so many incredible
Olivia sorry Olivia exactly I mean
Olivia thorby getting up there and just
doing all these wonderful improvisations
about her character and how she would
address the idea of was it necessary to
drop the bomb um you know after the
Nazis had surrendered I that was just
incredible and the extras there the
extras in that scene a lot of them were
scientists working at Los Alamos now and
so they're incredibly well educated on
the history and the issues involved and
so when you were do an improvisation
everybody from the act as we've talked
about to the extras would be uh throwing
in all kinds of useful and appropriate
uh discussion points I was determined to
end with this question you are one of
our top tier filmmakers I feel like
there are many people out there who you
know just picture you sitting there you
know working on your next Masterpiece or
watching films of this caliber but I
want to know I'm not going to call it a
guilty pleasure film I don't like that
term what is your comfort movie of
choice after a long day what is your
movie to unwind and relax with that you
could watch over and over I
mean too many to name really I don't
have particular films that I watch over
and over on a daily basis for that kind
of comfort I I look at the great spread
of them I revisit films by all of the
Masters my favorites are Ridley Scott
Stanley cubric things like that but I
also love romantic comedies you know uh
all kinds of films um I'm particularly
interested in between films I I watch a
lot of silent films big fan of that era
well it it takes you out
of contemporary film making out of the
process that you do out of the process
that that you your other filmmakers
working today do it gives you a
completely different way of looking at
uh the form and you know with all of the
great uh Library releases now you have
access to all of film history so uh I
very much enjoy just going back at
discovering things that uh films made in
a completely different way with a
completely different set of criteria uh
it makes you look at the medium
differently